I don't draw I haven't drawn since I was
a kid in fact here's a self-portrait of
me when I was 6 years
old and I know what you're thinking
pretty good right the semblance is
uncanny why was doing skin color so
difficult as a child it's like I'm not
completely white red burning fire red
here's another self-portrait I found
that I drew when I was 8 years old I
have now evolved skin color into merging
with the wall behind me old move an
artistic uh statement in comparison
here's a self-portrait that Picasso Drew
when he was 15 I was a prodigy I could
have been an artist but I stop I don't
draw so one of my last videos I did was
I learned a new thing every day for
seven days so I spent one day trying to
learn one thing and it was really fun it
got me itching to wanting to learn more
things and I thought what if I do it for
a longer time what if I learn to draw
then I can compare compare what I drew
at the beginning and then compare with
the end and be like wow at least that's
what you want to see right I have no
guarantees this could be very
embarrassing speaking of which I got to
draw my first drawing let's begin are
you guys ready to cringe it's all in
here be nice okay I'm a sensitive artist
I want only good feedback all right so
day one I drew a bunch of eyes because I
thought every day I'm going to learn to
draw a different body part that was a
bad
idea day two I just doodle which you
know is fun but my goal with this was to
get better right so yeah I drew a bunch
of stuff from my favorite manga blam you
can kind of tell it's just a mess I
don't even know
yeah it's embarrassing to show these day
three yeah still doing I don't know the
goal of this was not to just draw a lot
but rather just draw a little bit every
day so day four I watched a tutorial I
watched a draw Along by akihito Yosi uh
really cool style so drawing along yeah
I guess it helped but it still looks how
it looks like cool so here's kind of the
Crux of this video where I realized I
could never draw a girl because I don't
know about you guys but I am in the
girls are pretty guys are ugly gang okay
whatever you prefer that's fine but I
feel like if you draw a guy it doesn't
really matter they can be ugly what
whatever but if you draw a girl and you
want to make them pretty it's hard you
got to be good at drawing to do that so
I thought that would be a good challenge
to teach myself how to draw a girl and
here we have the result and it's
awful yeah that one's not too bad I
don't know what that is so I found this
artist on YouTube I recommend Chang
drawing that does a lot of tutorials and
I really like this style too because
they weren't anime style it was just
drawing girls and they look really good
but not mine so I learned the basic of
drawing the circle and the eyes and how
to proportion it all cuz if any element
is wrong the face just looks horrible it
doesn't matter what you do day six is
just in pain I was so frustrated trying
to understand this method of drawing a
circle and then I drew my first M here
uh it's horrible don't laugh at do not
screenshot these that's illegal do not
screenshot they all just kind of look
like weird elves or just leprechauns
rather I was very mad I'm cringing so
hard looking at
these I just can't seem to get it they
all look like
elves I don't know
why maybe cuz ear are
giant it's very frustrating it doesn't
get better actually sometimes I Dre
stuff and I'm like that one's not that
bad actually but then the rest is just
awful so day eight Drew my second merch
is bad I erased parts of it cuz I hated
it that
much Me and Mar went to a cafe uh we
wanted a break from parenting so Mar
just read a book and I just drew and it
was really really nice but I tried to
draw Ms but it was it's just so cringe
it's so bad I really thought I would be
better by day eight but here we are so
yeah it's more pain just pain I'm so mad
at drawing these so
furiated like why can't I draw what is
wrong sorry to interrupt the video
there's something I wanted to tell you
guys there's a g-fuel BOGO
sale
yes BOGO what does it mean I don't know
but you buy one you get one hooray we
also now have the PewDiePie black
stainless steel to celebrate Black
Friday it's the same one but more black
it looks amazing
that's how it looks like it's beautiful
they sold out super quick last time so
for those lucky who gets one probably
the best looking Shaker we've ever had
there's also a new PewDiePie blacklight
Edition tub that's right it glows in
black light got to buy it the first
5,000 people who buy this will get a
free gfuel branded keychain don't wait
cuz these things sell out and if you
spend more than $70 yeah what
you get this glowin the dark tub it
glows in the dark okay I don't know how
to draw that but it's it's for free over
$70 in this bogus sale there's so many
flavors included spiced orange twisted
metal ice cream which is sour strawberry
candy Mega Man's Rush Strawberry Slush I
love that wha fruit I love G fuel so
much it's clean energy gives you laser
focus zero sugar zero crack
Z what did I write Ser
stir anyway use code PewDiePie Link in
the description thanks for watching day
nine I guess I felt like I did a little
better that one's kind of fun I'm not
following any referend or anything I'm
just drawing based on what I learned uh
so sometimes they turn out one maybe out
of 10 day 10 not much to say day 11 I
felt like okay I should probably know
how to draw a body right so I practiced
that a lot it looks like I did a lot but
I I drew this so quickly that I don't
know just a lot of bodies started adding
heads to them and it was extremely hard
to for me to get the proportions of the
head and the body right as you can see
here on the right that's not
it yeah it's just kept drawing bodies
but I just hated them so I switched to
learning how to draw feet and hands for
a day just for a change of pace that was
easier I guess day 19 I was panicking at
this point cuz I knew knew I only had
what 10 more days and I hated these I
hate them maybe you guys will be like no
they're not that bad cuz that's what
Marc would always say which was really
encouraging but I hated them so much
what do you think
C you L yeah they're great thank you I
he's
beautiful what day 21 still panicking I
drew what looks like a child here I
didn't mean to I think the Torso was too
tiny yeah still panicking day 22 Yeah
day 23 oh God I drew another merch but
it's it was so bad I just scribble over
it sorry merch's face then I think here
on the LA these are not that bad I quite
like these what happened why can't I do
it every time why is it so hard to draw
Why did no one tell me day 24 I for
change of pace decided to draw some
anime characters you can see Power on
the left I followed a tutorial online as
well this really helped a lot I think
drawing anime style was just easier
somehow and following a reference was
also way easier they're not good by any
means but I was finally finally I just
felt like I clicked I could draw these
super quick and it was fun I was just
sketching random stuff Drew one quick
one moved on to the next one and I
really really enjoyed it after 24 days I
was finally having
fun same with day 25 I was like oh these
are even better I'm kind of improving
now I drew these all really quickly too
and messing around with different facial
expressions same in Day 26 I feel like
you every day you can see Improvement
and I drew another merch and that one's
not that bad day 27 I randomly picked up
this manga to study Japanese but I
really like the character it's called
Kindergarten Wars it was really fun to
draw this character I really really
enjoyed it just like goofy style chbi or
whatever but also kind of cute some
stuff day 28 I couldn't believe it it I
could felt like I could finally
draw I'm not saying these are great but
they're so much better than they used to
be all of a sudden it just kind of
clicked I was so happy I feel like it's
a bit cringe for a 34y old man to draw
anime but at least I feel like I was
improving and that was all I was going
with these are all from different anime
or Manga but I feel like they're quite
good I don't want to sound like arrogant
but I looked at these and I was like I
couldn't believe I drew them I drew
these how day 29 improveed still and I
drew a mar and I love it it's so cute
and that one's cute too what happened
finally uh these are pretty bad
but I don't know I like these and there
we go day 30 I don't like all of these
but some of them are kind of cool drew
them just from my head as well so I'm
happy about that and guess what day 31 I
kept going because I actually realized I
enjoy drawing now it's fun I'm really
sick of drawing anime girls or girls in
general but that was the goal to try and
accomplish comparing these and these
drawings with some of the first stuff I
drew you can at least say it's an
improvement we can agree on that so yeah
I was very pleasantly surprised all
right so that concludes my little
drawing thing honestly this is was a
better result than I expected my goal
was to practice 10 minutes a day because
now as a new dad I don't really have to
sit down for hours and do anything
because 10 minutes a day for 30 days
only equates to 5 hours so I wanted to
see you actually get a result out of
that and I think yeah it seems for me at
least I'm very happy and I enjoyed it I
thought it was fun after all the
pain the first two 3 weeks of pain I
felt like I was actually really enjoying
sketching I thought it was really
relaxing engaging and I can totally see
myself keep doing it keep a Sketchbook
and draw whatever but if you enjoyed
this video let me know maybe I inspired
you to learn something yourself 10
minutes a day not that big of a deal
that's it bye-bye